that was the scene 10 years ago today in
nasa's jet propulsion laboratory in
california when the curiosity rover
landed on the surface of mars time to
see where our curiosity will take it
a 2 000 pound car sized lab on wheels it
sent back incredible images and began a
scientific exploration of the red planet
it was huge and it is huge the mission
is ongoing we're still making big
discoveries john grant is a senior
geologist at the smithsonian national
air and space museum and a member of
curiosity's science team curiosity as a
rover went to mars with its lab
equipment with its cameras with its
instruments
and really started probing into whether
there were habitable environments in the
past on mars
and lo and behold we discovered fairly
early on in the mission that in fact
there there were and liftoff of the
atlas 5 with curiosity
curiosity was launched into space from
cape canaveral on november 26
2011. eight months 10 days and 100
million miles later it finally arrived
and three weeks later curiosity was
sending back stunning images from the
planet's surface but it was also on the
move
its seven foot robotic arm is designed
to scoop up soil samples and drill into
rocks looking for the chemical building
blocks of life curiosity landing and
gale crater has found this evidence of a
pass lake that's a really big deal we
know that that lake was there for a very
long time that's another big deal and we
know that the chemistry of that lake was
such that if life had been there it
probably could have survived that's
another huge deal the original mission
was only slated to last two years but
it's been extended multiple times this
is a nuclear-powered rover and it's got
a finite lifetime just because of the
the slow decay of that power source over
time but for now we're perking along
we're doing very well the rover i in my
sense is is active today as it as it was
10 years ago and now curiosity has
company
[Applause]
just last year nasa landed the next
generation rover perseverance complete
with its tiny flying drone ultimately
nasa hopes humans won't get just a
remote view of the red planet but will
see it for themselves let's cut to the
chase how soon before we will see
astronauts
heading you know landing
on mars in terms of time when people
might have boots on the ground on mars
gosh i hope it's in in something like 10
years but it wouldn't surprise me at all
if it's quite a bit more time than that
it's an expensive proposition and a
dangerous one and a dangerous one
dangerous but it's my understanding as
he explained it that that humans are
actually much faster at getting things
done or would be
on mars than any of the rovers so it's
why they say we're needed up there
yeah we wouldn't exactly withstand the
cold temperatures as well as they would
but yes i think we can probably think a
little bit better about some things
absolutely and just seeing those images
that they beam back i mean it is awe
inspiring no matter how old you are no
matter what you've seen anytime i think
of space though i have to give
a moment of of thought to the loss of
michelle nichols earlier this week
because
what she was able to do for nasa and
bringing so many people
of color and women into the program
there was a documentary we did woman in
motion it is now up for an emmy in fact
we found out this week that she was up
that that was up for an emmy at the same
time the same week she passed away